we're going to keep going with this
because we have retired army lieutenant
general Keith Kellogg he's also a Fox
News contributor he can give us his
thoughts and tell us where we are right
or wrong but mostly I'm sure we're right
as you will
say yeah thanks for having me I'm not
going to go where Greg was at though
look here's one of the things that the
reason why you want to get to a level of
deterrence and deterrence is based on
credibility of what you're doing and I
know it feels good to bomb 85 targets
with thousands of pounds of Munitions on
it and rip your shirt off and pound your
chest but if you don't establish
deterrence with credibility it's just
going to continue and my concern is that
we haven't really gone to the root cause
and the root cause is Iran and that's
where you have to go you have to go
downtown to establish that and why is
that important because when you look at
the Middle East I'm not I'm looking at
the Middle East when they people have
talked well it's the most dangerous has
been since 1973 no I think the world's
approaching the most dangerous State
since
1938 when the British prime minister
Neville ch Chamberlain went to Munich
and he came out of Munich after talking
to Hitler and he said oh peace in our
time then you started a world war wars
generally start by big mistakes and this
is getting to be a big mistake area
you're looking at Iran that is getting
ready to go nuclear they're already
enriching almost at 90% of of uranium
and when you get to 90% you can create
an at a nuclear weapon and if they get
that it'll tot totally
destabilizes in the Middle East you you
react differently to a nuclear power
than to a non-nuclear power you see all
the destabilization there and we we're
not forcing ourselves and forcing the
rest of the world to understand this has
gone about as far as we want to go
stabilize the region and and we're not
going there and so we're letting the
Chinese get involved Chinese make a a a
deal a peace deal between Saudi Arabia
and Iran that would have never happened
previously and you look at what's
happening in Ukraine and Russia and the
Far East with China and this all impacts
and and I think what we're doing right
now is we're feeling good we're bombing
a a lot of sand and a lot of asphalt but
we're not going after the root cause and
I hate to say it but we haven't gone
into Iran and I know that if you do that
the risk goes up I've got that but
you've got to get uncomfortable when you
do something like that to make the other
side uncomfortable Iran does not want to
go to war with the United States of
America they are afraid of the United
States they know what we can do and we
should make them understand that we are
going to take a step that is going to
prevent you from doing anything further
that means take out their their economic
fac ities like their oil fields that
means taking out their leadership either
either Ismail gani the leader of the
cuds force you're talking about kamini
the Supreme Leader you're talking about
taking out all the the their uh military
facilities you've got to be willing to
go there and when the other side
realizes that you're willing to step up
and go there they're going to back down
right now we have not sent that message
at all and I don't think this campaign
has a good end state to it right now
judge you know there there's no question
General that we I believe have the
military ability and capacity to be able
to have a war with Iran I'm not
promoting it I I'm not interested in
that I'm not interested in World War I
but to continue to say we don't want a
conflict with Iran if they don't want to
conflict with us and if that is your
opinion why are we so afraid to at least
threaten them to at least take out some
infrastructure to at least take out some
of the oil fields why are we so afraid
well it's Capac we've got the capacity
and capability that that's without
question it all comes down to leadership
and there's the commander-in-chief
Article 2 Section two there's the
president and it's his decisionmaking as
his advisers as well and I really think
they're risk averse you know the what
your adversaries do they read your
leadership they do that we do that as
well we say okay we know this leader is
probably going to react this way this
leader is going to react that way and
they look at somebody like a President
Biden who has traditionally been risk
averse we all set patterns you set
patternss I set patterns you go to the
same service station you go to the same
grocery store you set those patterns as
leadership as well and they see a leader
who's very risk averse and doesn't want
to go there so they're going to push the
envelope you've got to break that you've
got to break away from that that's the
only way you reach a conclusion there's
nothing to do with capacity we got
plenty of that and I think the Iranians
have said I think we can push this guy
and that's exactly what we're doing I
understand that's a harsh assessment I
know that but I think it's true if I
heard you correctly what I heard you
described as something akin to what
Lindsey Graham might have tweeted the
other day when he said bomb Tran you
might have not targeted Teran but you
talked about oil fields you talked about
a direct hit on Iran and you suggested
that any type of hit like that would
back Iran down from this aggressive
stance I'm just curious what would be
your historical precedent if you're
selling that to the American people that
we are going to take an aggressive
action against some nation state and
they will back down and this will not
anasti into a greater War can you give
me that when that happened in American
history that was a great
success oh sure I give you a lot of them
I'll start with the Civil War when Grant
Mar s shman down to the Sea and they
burned Atlanta you come you br keep
coming towards us towards this way when
the United States of America sent a
clear message in World War II when we
firebombed dresen into the ground when
we bombed nakazaki and Hiroshima with an
atomic weapon instead of invading those
things happen all the time I'm curious
about just I'm sorry to interrupt what
I'm curious about the two examples you
gave us of the Civil War and World War
II were clearly wide worldwide
metastasized actions that resulted in
millions of death I thought you were
describing an aggressive attack in Iran
to avoid a greater
War I I'll give you one simple example
what happened during the administration
with President Trump when we killed
solomani very clear we killed solomani
and things quieted down we took out one
key leader I'll give you another good
example when we when we were having
peace discussions with with the Taliban
and president Trump and I was in the
Oval Office when he talked to Muller
barer who is a leader of the Taliban it
was translated and I sat there wondering
boy how is this being translated but we
said very clearly what we were going to
do to him and the Taliban if something
happened and after that discussion not a
single American was killed in over a
year in Afghanistan you send a certain
message to certain people they receive
the message because they believe you're
serious so I can give you we can spend
an hour if you want to well I can give
you his historical example from
historical example from the third Punic
War to currently where it goes what you
do with leadership but it makes a hard
decision to do it but you've got to make
that call sometimes that doesn't mean
you totally bomb aan but you are very
selective in your targeting and it needs
to be done uh so General thanks for
joining us so I guess my question to to
sort of pick up where where will left
off is this idea that if we decide that
we're going to preemptively strike in
Iran right and are you saying that we do
not you do not believe that the Iranians
would retaliate in some sort of way
given the fact that we have a lot of
troops in that region and I think we
said earlier in the show many of them
are in they're in in bases that we
already lost three there we 40 injured
are we saying that there's not there's
no potential for the Iranians to strike
back and hurt American troops on the
ground
there of course there is Richard but I
I'll take issue with one word you used
for us to preemptively attack Iran
they've been attacking us for the last
90 days they've been striking all facil
they secure forces and we and we would
go after them of course we would have to
accept that that's the risk level not a
gamble but there's a risk level you take
but you make sure they understand if you
want to dance with the bear the United
States being the bearer we will decide
when the dance stops not you and you
make that hard call look I'm not big on
starting a war I've had kids in the
military I've been in the military but I
also understand what you have to do to
establish some level of deterrence in
the world and in the region and we're
not there yet and you have to establish
that if not you're heading for a larger
War more conflict More Death more
Americans have been lost we've been
dodging a bullet for the last 90 days it
finally hit home with the deaths of
three great Americans and that could
continue into the future this thing has
not stopped not at all and I would like
to know what is the end state of this
contingency plan that the United States
has established with all this bombing I
don't know where they're going to they
need to tell us well they called a lid
so I don't think we're going to get that
tonight thank you General Kellogg let's
bring hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now